When you think of leaving the Earth, you probably
think of something like this:
This is the Saturn V launching Apollo 11 to
the Moon.
It was a chemical rocket, burning a mixture
of kerosene and liquid oxygen to get its payload
— the Apollo astronauts — off the Earth.
Chemical rockets are basically an exercise
in brute force, but they’re not the best
way to go.
They use a ton of resources, are bad for the
environment, and can kill people.
What if there was a better, easier, cheaper,
less environmentally disastrous way of leaving
the planet?
One company, Zero2Infinity, is working on
a different method today using rockoons.
Rockoons are a hybrid of a rocket and a balloon
that split the process of reaching orbit into
two parts: First, the balloon rises into the
upper atmosphere, then the rocket adds the
needed momentum to launch something into orbit
or to another planet.
In March of 2017, Zero2Infinity, launched
a balloon to about 82,000 feet.
At that point, they were above 99 percent
of the atmosphere, so they ignited a small
solid rocket motor.
Another company, ACRA, is using a rockoon-type
launch system for its entry into the Google
Lunar X Prize competition.
But if using a balloon to lift a rocket seems
like old technology, it’s because it is…
The concept originated in March of 1949 for
better, high-altitude atmospheric science.
Rockoons are actually a simple and ingenious
approach to spaceflight.
Instead of fighting against gravity, they
turn gravity into an advantage.
A small sounding rocket is suspended beneath
a large balloon made of super thin plastic
— usually polyethylene — that is filled
with a small amount of helium.
As the balloon rises, the atmospheric pressure
gets lower and the helium heats, allowing
it to expand and fill the volume of the balloon.
The balloon can then ascend to a point where
it’s above most of the atmosphere, meaning
the rocket suspended beneath it is in a near
vacuum.
It’s at this point the rocket fires, and
because there’s almost no atmosphere, the
rocket is much more efficient.
Another benefit of rockoons is that they can
accommodate all kinds of payloads.
Satellites on rockets need to be folded and
housed in fairings, basically an aerodynamic
case, to keep them safe from launch vibrations
and fit them on top of the rocket.
With a rockoon, because the rise to launch
altitude is slow and smooth, the air doesn’t
tear apart the thing you’re launching.
This means the payload can be less aerodynamically
sound and still fly safely.
It’s just protected by a lightweight fairing.
Perhaps the most famous use of rockoons was
a series of launches done by James Van Allen
in August and September of 1952.
He was able to send instruments 50 miles up
to test radiation near the Earth’s poles.
It was through these launches that van Allen
discovered there was significant radiation
at high altitude.
Follow up observations with the Explorer 1
satellite in 1958 allowed van Allen to discover
the radiation belts that bear his name.
Of course, mentioning the Van Allen belts
usually gets people pointing to them and crying
foul saying, “we can't go through them to
get to the Moon, so we never went to the Moon.”
Well, astronauts did.
I’ve got a video going into those details
on my own channel Vintage Space.
And speaking of the Moon and other planets,
should Pluto be a planet again?
We talk about how it could be in this video.
What’s your favourite, non-traditional way
to get into space?
Let us know in the comments, give us a like,
and subscribe so you never miss an episode.